[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so my name is Hannah Howard you heard a
little bit about me just so if you want
to find me on the Internet's that's my
little icon and my handle act Edgar
Wonder will work for almost any social
media site that I wish for the public to
have access to to find me um and I work
for a company called carbon five we're a
product development agency and we
basically work with all kinds of clients
from startups all the way to like big
enterprises trying to help them take
their products from from concept all the
way to completion and I definitely need
to give that spiel because they pay for
me to be here which is really cool so um
this talk is called
oh wait I'm a little lost here in my dad
[Music]
sorry okay let's try this again
okay rxjs a better way to write
front-end applications what's going on
here sorry I'm here we go I'm really
sorry just give me one second this is
not how it's supposed to work I'm giving
away all the secrets this is terrible oh
my god oh no now you all know everything
about it maybe that's it what's okay
yeah Wow okay how about now okay
whoo one more time what
yeah okay sorry I am going yes brief
contact warning before we start okay
well now you've already seen the whole
talk so it's really great it's a great
talk
you could leave now if you want anyway
there is as you might have noticed some
possibly jarring animation in this talk
so I'm trying to be a little more
sensitive to those issues so if you are
someone who's sensitive to that
definitely this mean it's not super
jarring but you may want to be aware of
that and then the other thing this isn't
really a Content warning but there will
be heavy pop-culture references because
I'm from Los Angeles and that is what we
do so good evening ladies a good evening
and good morning to all of you legendary
children and welcome to the functional
reactive programming ball tonight the
category is what is a computer program
so I refer to a very important computer
science textbook and often in my
programming and it defines a computer
program as a sequence of instructions
designed to solve specific problems and
I think that phrase is really
interesting it's the one I always get
focused on sequence of instructions it
makes it sound like our programming
programming is just like writing a to-do
list you're like do this and that not
noting that um and or if you were to
think about it in maybe a different
context you might think of it like a
lesson plan basically a you know a
series of steps to do a lesson but is it
really like that is that an accurate
description maybe if we were writing a
command line tool that would be accurate
but we're Java programmers right so I
imagine there's one of one or two of you
who writes front-end programs for the
web and this is the metaphor that I
think is more apt for how front-end
program run basically front-end programs
don't run sequentially they the flow of
execution is constantly interrupted by
user input and responses from servers
and a million other things we have way
less control it's like an unruly
classroom so in a way I think that
interruptions are kind of the central
challenge of front-end programming so
how do we deal with them well let's
let's learn from our history and look at
a brief history of how we've dealt with
interruptions on the front end so the
first idea we came up with or that
programmers came up with I wasn't one of
them
is something called the global event bus
and so I want to take you all the way
back to the very first programming that
I ever did which was writing games in
DOS that was an operating system in the
early 90s and 80s for those of y'all who
anyway one thing you could do in Dass is
you could actually like take over the
keyboard you could do something called
overriding the bios and basically take
control of the keyboard and so that you
were stepping in between yourself and
the hardware and like the rest of the
computer and you would write some code
they would basically take every key that
got pressed and you put it in some kind
of a buffer and then your main program
would be some kind of a loop like this
one right it would essentially be a loop
that looked at the last user input and
then did something with it and you know
essentially on each step you'd have to
check all of your inputs not just the
keyboard this is a simpler version and
then act on it until whatever happened
that was gonna quit the program what
happened there was an issue with that
which is that if you wrote a bad
keyboard handler like this this is not
only gonna loop forever but you can't
type anything on the keyboard so your
computer will be fixed by pressing the
button at the bottom of it back when we
had desktop computers anyway this is
improved upon a little bit with a
Windows program in which I touched on
which I did just a tiny bit of but it's
basically the same idea the operating
system took over talking directly to the
hardware so you couldn't do that sort of
mistake there but the basic
is the same you read process and
dispatch messages and then the main
logic of your program would be to handle
different messages right and they
usually ended up looking like a big
switch statement where you did something
based on the message that was passed and
that is that's sort of the pattern and
that takes us all the way up to like
1999 or so right um and and when we
moved on and let that in the dust for
much better things but actually if
you've been programming recently that
sort of pattern for like dealing for
updating state based on dispatched
messages if you happen to be programming
react you might notice that that looks a
lot like a reducer and in fact Redux
contains a whole lot of the global event
bus pattern
so while Redux may be programming like
it's 1999 in in in reality there are
some good reasons they went that way and
we're gonna see in a second but I want
to go ahead and move on to the observer
pattern which is basic from redux this
is how we've written front-end
applications for the last several years
to do before we get into that I want to
I need to make a short digression if you
all don't mind into the world of
influencers so and and it's gonna help
us understand the observer pattern I
promise so let's say you are a content
creator on the internet and you know
with your typewriter you have something
very important to say and you're
wondering how will people see my content
right so in the pre-internet age you
kind of had to be like Liam Neeson and
you had to track down anybody who you
wanted to see your content and just like
force them to watch it but fortunately
now we have a better way we we see we
have like a contract I is a contract
content creator promise to publish
content and then you as my adoring fans
use one of our many and numerous scary
social media surveillance platforms to
subscribe to it
and then when I publish new content you
will get you'll essentially
automatically get notified without me
having to go track you down right so
this in short is the observer pattern
here our influencer is called the
subject and they essentially promise
that they will admit events in the
future and then you have an observer who
subscribes to those events and then can
act on them so that's the that's the
basic pattern and you actually probably
use it every day you probably use this
in your JavaScript code without knowing
it I'm gonna look at a really short
real-world example and so we use this
Paso Sun yeah still I'm still like
rewinding myself from the beginning of
this and getting myself under the right
slides so sorry if I'm catching up but
okay
so let's say that we have like a DOM and
the Dom has a toggle switch and and we
want to make it so that when you click
on that toggle switch it changes
something from on to off so we have our
toggle switch there's there there we've
looked it up and then we have a function
that is going to look at another element
in the Dom and basically switch its
value from on to off right so this is a
pure function and then we have the and
then we have this element so the way
that we connect these two is we
essentially subscribe the we subscribe
to mouse clicks on the toggle switch and
then pass it to this function which is
now an event handler right it's it is
now an observer of the quick events on
the toggle switch and that means that
when we click the toggle switch will
switch the the text in that other
element so that's the basics of the
observer pattern you've probably been
using it without knowing so um cool so
there's some really cool advantages here
right
it's way simpler than the global event
bus right like we didn't have to write a
giant loop we didn't have to write a big
switch statement we just attached to
what we cared about and so it's really
localized
right you just subscribe to the only the
things you care about and then you
process them when they happen the
downside is that you have to set up
subscriptions which start initially
doesn't sound like a pain too much of a
pain but there's a take home exercise I
highly encourage you to try implementing
drag and drop or if you've ever done
this implementing drag and drop with
like Mouse down mouse up and mouse over
it's it's quite a challenge and a lot of
the problem is that you're actually
mixing concerns right you have you're on
the one hand you're handling events
right you are so you have these event
handlers but then the event handlers
themselves have to also set up other
subscribers other event handlers cuz
like basically when you when you do the
Mouse down then you want to start
tracking Mouse move and then when you do
that get the mouse up you want to stop
tracking Mouse move so there's a lot of
different logic it gets pretty
complicated and the observer pattern is
really great and it's been around a long
time it's reliable but it's not really
perfect so this is my theory of how
redux got created is that the Redux
creators we're looking at this global
event bus we're looking at the observer
pattern and then they saw the global
event bus and they were like maybe
there's something valuable going on here
but you might be wondering like maybe
there's just a better way to do all this
yeah
so that's kind of the rest of my talk
this is about how you can reuse a
functional reactive programming to write
front ends like a boss I want to return
to my original metaphor of the the
middle school classroom and actually in
reference to the speaker I did actually
teach but the lies that I taught middle
school not high school which is arguably
even harder but it wouldn't matter
either way because I was terrible at it
and and this this is not a talk about
how to be a bad teachers is about how
good teachers handle situations and if
you've ever like watched a good teacher
in action they're kind of like they're
cut a Jedi like right like they have
this ability to like like Oh
be one the students into like thinking
this is the lesson they're looking for
right and and so how do they do that
right they they do it the first rule is
that like the lesson plan is not like a
series of steps it's not a plan it's
kind of more of a guide because if they
treat it like a plan they're just gonna
get interrupted instead teaching you'd
almost think of actual teaching as a
series of plan responses to
interruptions right and really good
teachers know how to not just respond to
the interruption but to sort of like
fold that interruption back into the
rest of the lesson right and they and
they have this wayward just sort of like
each interruption gets folded into the
stream of learning that always ends up
on the key objectives of what they're
trying to teach um so in that sense it
almost is Jedi mind control um
PSA is someone who's really bad at
teaching I highly encourage our society
to pay teachers a lot so what does this
have to do with programming how do we
write programs that where we where we
write them as planned reactions to
interruptions as our core concept well
so I want to take a another digression
into just some pure conceptual stuff
let's look at this statement really
basic y equals x plus three you've
probably written something of this sort
in your programs at some point in your
programming career and if we think about
it in our traditional sense in the
imperative programming world this is an
assignment right you're saying that Y is
gonna be equal to whatever the current
value of x is plus three one time and
now it has that value and it will be
that way for a while um but and I can
tell you already there's a missing image
coming up in this one I'm not sure what
happened if if we think about math in
math it actually has a different meaning
in math y equals x plus three can
express an entire graph right you can
express its expresses uh what is it like
I slope-intercept thing on a graph I'll
have to talk to the math majors
afterwards but anyway that's what it
should there should be a graph there
there's not so so it doesn't have to
mean that and if we look at reactive
programming we we could with this
statement y equals x plus three could
actually express a relationship between
y and X and it's essentially saying that
X is a value that could change over time
and Y is a value that will always be
that value plus 3 right so do you
imagine oh my god what's going on with
my images okay I'm not gonna
troubleshoot this cuz we don't have
enough time sorry this was working as of
like two seconds ago you can imagine a
line with lots of expo and you can
imagine why as another line that doesn't
look like a broken piece of paper and
and and there's another there's another
line of values under it and each value
for X has a value for Y underneath it
that is that value plus 3 and then you
can even get another missing and so
you've said those are both like a stream
of data values over time but a stream of
could be a stream of anything it could
be a stream of mouse-clicks over time
you can imagine just like every time the
user clicks a mouse you add a new value
onto this stream right um
so reactive programming is essentially
programming with data with streams of
data and that's all well and good but
how would we program this on a computer
which is basically written to use to
work imperative ly to execute
instructions we need some kind of
pattern where like every time a value
changes the you could like subscribe to
it and get notified that it was changing
and I feel like we've heard of that
pattern it's actually the observer
pattern we just need to basically extend
it make it a
better to handle kind of like arbitrary
things right so in reactive programming
we have a concept called an observable
and an observable is a is essentially a
value that changes over time that we can
listen for changes on but it could be
anything so let's imagine a value as an
observable so let's imagine we have a
value X that is a value that changes
over time that we can subscribe to and
here you could write out the changes to
X and then you can imagine if you wanted
to write out the values of Y you could
just subscribe to the changes on X and
log X plus 3 right but what if we
actually wanted to listen to the values
on Y right so to figure this out let's
uh let's rewind for a second and just
imagine X as an array right so it's an
array of values and if we wanted to get
the array of Y values from this in
JavaScript and a lot of programming
languages we could use the map operation
which takes essentially an array of
values goes through each one transforms
it and gives you back the array where
each values been transformed by the
function so an observable actually works
the exact same way here we have an
observable of these numbers and here
they would just be output it immediately
but we could think of them as happening
over time and we could think of Y as the
observable X mapped so that each value
is the emitted value plus 3 and that
produces another observable we could
subscribe to so this is where the magic
of reactive programming happens you have
these observables which you can compose
and continue to sort of like build up to
do really awesome things so let's look
at some cool stuff um it's gonna be our
first interactive demo and I need to get
over to the confidence screen given
there ok so here we have a ball right
and uh PS a full disclosure this is
animated with a library but we could
let's say we have these two buttons
right and the buttons we can use them to
we can use them to make the ball go left
and right right
so let's imagine that each time we click
on one of these buttons it's an
observable right and so we have our left
button clicks and a right button clicks
and if I click on the right button you
we can imagine that we would get a quick
right so then what if we take each right
button click and translate it to the
string right and each left button click
and translate it to the string left
right so now if I quick it becomes right
and if I could if I click left it
becomes left so then let's now further
imagine that we make an observable that
uses the left click position in the
right position and just takes whatever
the last the last one to admit is so now
we have like a left click a left click
and a left click so the position is left
and if we had a right click then the
position is right so you can see that
basically by doing this the position is
now an observable of the correct
position for the ball to be in right now
the actual animation in this case is
being done with this library called pose
but um you can you could I met but it's
not that complicated to do so um how
this actually works in code and here's
where we're gonna introduce the library
that I that we used to do reactive
programming in JavaScript it's called rx
yes and we have two functions here to
create observables one that it makes it
observable from an event and one called
merge which takes two observables and
outputs that observable that emits both
of that both of their events so um and
then we have some operators we have a
map operator a start with operator and
delay we actually aren't using here but
that's what is being used in those
animations of the actual signals and so
here you have like a left button and a
right button that are we just looked up
from the Dom and then we've made an
event stream of both of their clicks and
then this is actually mapping each one
from a quick to a string and in actual
rxjs code we use this pipe operator and
then we put our different operations in
the middle and the cool thing about that
is you can do multiple of them so here
we're piping left the left and right to
position oh sorry
and then finally we're merging them
right we are merging we're using that
merge operator to take the two of them
and we're adding one other thing which
is we want to start it in the left
position cool so how do I actually use
this in my daily life you're all excited
this looks cool you saw a bouncy ball
but how do we actually do this um well I
want our first stop talk about something
that I noticed how many of you all went
to Laurie boss's talk on NPM yeah a
bunch of you you all remember this graph
about the react ecosystem so when he
headed up I was looking at it and I was
like wait a second what's that green
line wait isn't that I was like holy
moly it's rjs and it's got more
downloads than a react so this short the
short answer we actually spent some time
yesterday I spent the time with Laurie
try to figure out how this happened as
it turns out rxjs is used by some key
libraries namely angular and es lint or
dependencies thereof so it's it's
installed by that
um so even if you are programming with
rxjs you actually are it's somewhere
it's it's a lot of the people whose
libraries you depend on program with
rxjs um so but i want to talk about how
you would use it to actually write
programs of your own I mean I want to
address two areas one is first how do I
actually architect a real application
with rxjs and how do i integrate this
into my like applications today so let's
talk briefly about a much more
real-world example I mean here we have a
login form one of our classic you know
software challenges you have to like be
able to enter a user and password when
you submit you probably want to disable
everything until it comes back with the
response you have like a user you want
to give a message or something you know
the server tells you that something went
wrong you've got somewhere in here an
asynchronous call out to a back-end so
there's a lot going on here right and so
what so in assembling this we could
start with three observables a username
a password and a submit button and
basically the user name would emit any
time that I changed
the value of the username and the
password would admit every time that I
changed the value of the password and
the submit button you can think of just
going whenever I quit the Smith so then
if I were to express the act of
attempting to login it would essentially
be the every time I click the submit
button take the last value of the
username and password and it's an
attempt a login with them so here like
so essentially with that if I actually
do is if I Smith here it takes those
last values and you can see those the
username and password there are the last
thing that was emitted from those from
these input boxes and so then once I
have a login attempt then I need to
process the response that gets backward
then I get back from the server and that
could be either a success or a fail
right so I can so basically once that
comes back I'm gonna go ahead and I get
my attempt and then I get a response in
that case it's a failure right once I
have that I can do some more stuff I
could filter down to just failures and
just successes I might be able to derive
like a login in progress from the time
between a login attempt and a login
login response and that might be useful
for like disabling all these inputs
while the logon is happening and then I
might have then once I have a failure I
don't want to convert it to a message so
I can display it on the screen and
lastly if I have a success I might have
a user token and I might use that to get
some like protected data from the server
so all taken all together you have like
Kourt you could do quite a bit of
functionality with observables and I'll
show you the actual code for this in a
second but you can see here like you see
a failure message sort of trickling down
into the fail the the final fail message
and then over here on the login in
progress you have like the you know it
tracks whether or not you're logging in
and then if we were to do a success
which is J is calm and awesome then
we get a success and that gets a user
token and that gets a protected resource
and then we get your final like save
data so that's you can imagine it
filtering around
how would that actually happen in code
it's not actually as complicated as you
might think making that little graph is
pretty complicated but um but writing
the code to do this is not terrible
let's just imagine we have an API with a
login and a pretend with the login
endpoint and a protected resource
endpoint of some sort so there's our API
and then let's just say we have our
username password and submit button I
will get to how those work tie into the
actual UI in a second and then we can do
our login attempt it just becomes the
submit button with an operator from rxjs
called with latest from which basically
just says take the latest username and
password and add it to whatever the
login attempt whatever the whenever the
submit button is quick and then we have
a login response uses this amazing
operator called merge map in in rxjs and
here we actually make an API call which
returns a promise which is not something
that has an immediate value but if you
use merge map it essentially takes you
know you what you do when you make the
API call if you were to just use map you
would get a stream of promises but merge
map will reduce those down to just their
underlying values when they arrive so
this actually gives you a stream of the
responses and then the login in progress
is just expressed as essentially every
login attempt flipping it to true and
every login response flipping it to
false and starting with false right the
login successes can be expressed by
taking the login response and just like
we would with an array we can use a
filter operator right and here we're
filtering and just taking the status and
converting it to a success um and then a
login failure would just be the same
thing but but filtering on the status
being failure a login failure message
would be taking all the login failures
and just piping them to extract
to a map operation to extract the
message a user token would be extracting
a token out of the success responses and
then we could start the whole set the
whole sequence all over again to get the
protected resource and here we're taking
the user tokens and piping those to make
an API request with the user token to
get a protected resource so that's how
you could do some very complex
functionality and not a whole lot of
code using arcs yes know that graph
you've seen it's a really important
concept in rxjs that the more you get
into it I wish more people knew about
this it's called a signal graph right
and it's how data propagates through
your program and it's a really useful
tool for thinking about your programs
and gosh darn it oh I figured it out
it's SVG's so that's an SVG but it's an
SVG of a real signal graph and we i've
actually programmed on production
applications where the whole team
maintains this signal breath as a way of
like producing a shared understanding
between the whole team about how you're
doing you know about basically how the
data model of your entire application
works so how would you use this in real
life I'm getting real close so let's
talk about integrating at natural stuff
first of all if you use angular and I
actually don't use angular but if you do
use angular it's like basically baked
into the framework at a million ways and
there's a million really easy ways to
use rxjs and angular also you might want
to check out our ng rx do I also
encourage you to like not that's sort of
like a big library that kind of operates
like Redux and I encourage you to like
not jump right to using the the library
and try learning a little bit more about
how our X works but let's get to the
question on everybody's mind about react
because if you're if you're writing a
program in react and you have reactive
Jas wouldn't it be better to have like
reactive in your react so there's good
news I am here to offer you something in
this there's actually a whole bunch of
different ways to do to to integrate
react with rxjs and and full disclosure
i'm going to present my way as in the
software that i wrote because i cause
i'm talking but there are a lot of other
great alternatives and i highly
heard you to look at them so I wrote a
library called rx react and it's a
series of tools for integrating react
with rxjs and in fact everything you've
seen in those interactive demos was
written with this with rx react and the
way it works it's pretty simple actually
right let's say you how this is in this
example this is our box that's like
moving backward and forward in our inner
screen right and what we do with rx
react is we define something called a
view model this is similar to this is
basically drawing from a pattern called
model view viewmodel which basically a
view model is like the thing that
supplies the data to the to the view
which just does the presentation right
um in this case with a view model it
connects our observables into props in
react in this case here's our inputs and
the and for each input it's going to
convert the observable here we have a
position observable into a prop called
position any time it up that's gonna
update any time it updates right oh
sorry
and and so each inputs an observable it
becomes a prop and you define this as a
view model and then you import from this
library rx react core because rx react
was already taken on NPM you import a
function called with view model and view
model is just a higher-order component
that takes your view model and binds it
to your regular components so now this
component anytime the positions
observable updates it will rerender with
a new position prop and you can do the
same thing actually for for events you
can you you have these things called
outputs and it for an output each value
here is some kind of is a special type
of observable called a subject and you
saw those in the slide earlier and
essentially it converts it from so this
subject the left click subject you will
get in your component you'll get a
property called on click which is itself
a function that when you call will put a
new value on to this on click observable
and omit it right so this basically it
converts from an observable emitting of
a from a function to an emission
an event on an observable you can
actually and and actually you can do
pretty complicated stuff pretty easily
this is this right here is the code for
that entire login form that I showed you
a second ago we have our username and
our password as inputs log you know our
login and progress state our login
failure messages and then we have we
also have a username and password change
which are the outgoing and this has to
do with the way that react does inputs
where you have to both like send it the
new value and read the events if you
want to do a controlled input and you
have a submit button and that's all
that's needed to connect that login form
um so now we come to the final portion
of this talk which is called the used
car sales portion because I'm gonna go
very quickly through all the amazing
cool things you get when you use RX
react if you act now
so one thing it has is these view model
factories like let's say you want to
change the observables based on the
props external to the component changing
well so you can use a view model Factory
to do that and that you use the same
function the with view model and you're
probably wondering but what about tight
script because you care about your stuff
not breaking you are concerned about the
security of your [ __ ] so the good news
is that rx react is written in tight
script cuz I love tight script too and
it actually has here I'm not gonna get
into it but if you're in tight script it
has really awesome type checking where
like all the props have to line up and
all the observables have to line up and
like you won't mess up and whatnot
or so I claim what if you're like I like
observables but I also like reducers um
cuz they're very hot right now well what
if you could write a view model based on
a reducer function similar to sort of
the syntax of reason ml which is
Facebook's new hotness in terms of like
the way they want to take react in the
future well guess what there's another
package called rx react a slash reducer
and it is also somewhat available now I
actually don't know if I published it
but what else and the rule need the
coolest thing that fascinates me is like
those signal graphs and
just imagine I would really like to be
able to automatically render one of
those interactive diagrams so I could
watch my programs do that doesn't exist
right now but I've got a lot of ideas
and I'm really working and one day there
will be our X react flash signal but in
the meantime I highly recommend our X
react slash core I used it enough that I
think it's not terrible so that's all
you can find my slides right there and
the github will be on the slides when
you get there and thanks let's go